uh
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to rotten tomatoes
binge battle my name is mark ellis i'm
your esteemed
host that's going to usher you through
four
possibly five scintillating rounds of
spirited debate all centered around
the boys no we're not talking about the
beatles tune the ringo starr once belted
out
it's the new hit show that is now
celebrating its second
certified fresh season season one's at
84 percent season two
certified fresh at 98 percent on the
tomato meter so a lot of people
are loving the boys right now but how
did jay washington and roxy striver feel
about it before i introduced
our competitors i'm gonna remind you all
that yes i am a stand-up comic
i have not been on stage in five months
so i'm very excited to shout out to the
world
i am finally doing a stand-up show
this weekend in the viper room 7 p.m
saturday
nine five i'm gonna be live virtually no
audience there which means you can watch
from anywhere in the world a lot like
you're doing right now tickets are as
low as twelve dollars you'll be telling
a lot of jokes you can comment on the
live chat you can come and heckle me
this is the one time i'll let you heckle
me during a comedy show in the live chat
very excited to have a lot of my great
comic friends open
for me i'll be on stage then do a q a
looking forward to being back on stage
telling jokes it's going to be a whole
lot of fun and now that we move on to
the actual binge battle portion of the
show called binge battle it is my
pleasure to welcome your two
binge competitors one of whom is a great
stand-up comic him and i performed
together from la to chicago to new york
and he is also a tremendous host actor
podcaster director extraordinaire he
does a lot of writing he does a lot of
artwork
he is the one the only birds in the hood
co-host
jay washington jay welcome back to binge
battle my friend
uh thank you brother i appreciate it i'm
glad to be back thank you for all the
amazing plugs
uh i appreciate it yes thank you for the
stand-up thing and i'm happy you're
getting back on stage i know how that
feeling was until i finally got back on
stage a month ago
i stepped on stage with a microphone and
i was like thank you jesus
but i forgot there was a show going on
like i was so happy to be on stage
but now i'm glad to be doing this again
man last time i had fun with this and
this time i get to have fun
again and i got to have fun with
somebody's ass i got a whoop
because i love and care about roxy so
much but this is gonna be
personal hey y'all we're already
throwing heat back and forth with each
other in our green room pre-show
and you mentioned your opponent here
today she is
an incredible actor writer producer
director star of the world girls and her
daily show on youtube live
at the roxy it is miss roxy streyer roxy
you've been on binge battle before
you've competed very well you've won
binge battle before
how do you feel about your odds today
going up against mr j
washington you know we have fought many
times in the past this will be no
different today
jay and i are a couple of arguing old
people
uh when it comes to this kind of thing
so listen i'm
i'm one and one right now i'm one and
one i'm one win
one loss today is going to be the
tiebreaker that either makes me one of
the greats or one of the losers and i
don't intend on being a loser
all right well roxy is a big fan of the
new england patriots who have six super
bowls jay's a big fan of the chicago
bears who have one super bowl but
celebrate that as though they had won
six so now i'm gonna read you the rules
of binge battle four rounds possibly a
fifth if we get to
sudden death and you the fan watching
right now
is gonna influence the debate how do you
do that well we welcome your eyeballs
wherever you're watching us from whether
it's fandango rotten tomatoes movie
clips
if you happen to be on youtube please
comment click subscribe
click that bell it's going to give you a
word every time a new binge battle drops
but if you're watching us on facebook
right now the rotten tomatoes facebook
page
you can comment chime in i'll be reading
a lot of the comments during the action
and
most importantly you are voting for who
you think is the better debater or who
you think had the better argument heck
which side are you on you're gonna click
that like button
you're gonna click that love button the
thumbs up the blue button that's if you
think roxy had a better round and you
want her
to win if you click that hearth the red
button that's you saying jay washington
dominated that round
and he deserves the point each round was
worth one point and like i said we could
get to sun dead it's happened a lot
before
it could happen with the boys so roxy
jay let me ask you all a quick warm-up
question start with your roxy then we'll
quickly go to jay
when did you first come about the
streaming show the boys did you hop on
right away or did you have to binge and
catch up
right away immediately was watching this
was looking forward to it premiering
and actually just re-binged the entire
season one
to prepare for today and i gotta say it
plays even better on a second watch
you catch some things that you didn't
catch the first time i
have been obsessed from day one and i
cannot
wait for season two this is getting me
even more excited
it's already certified fresh at 98 jay
when did you first cross
the boys san diego comic-con last year
when they debuted there when they had
the uh
activation for amazon and everything and
then later on in that evening
we got to watch the first episode and
then watching that and then like wait
let me just see what this is because
i've never been familiar with the comic
and so when i saw it i just kept
watching it i was like
yo and i've rewatched it several times
and i've had the pleasure
to see the upcoming season so i'm like
it's gonna just continue to be better
several times humble brag okay okay
hey it's all about those advanced
screeners uh we already have a very
active chat room i see uh
adaberto rios says too far ellis i guess
in reference to my chicago hey you all
still one in 85 and you can ask
can that was 35 years ago
we're now sitting on 16 tight ends and
that hurts
the bears really do sign a lot of tight
ends all right let's move on
to round number one of binge battle here
we go
your premise the boys it's a simple
question
good or bad jay washington
you're going to start with your minute
opening salvo
have at it when you look at the boys
you're looking at billy butcher you're
looking at huey you're looking at
mother's milk you're looking at frenchie
and you're wondering what they're doing
they're trying
to expose vat for all of its flaws and
its lack of and with the soups but the
problem
is how they go about it so my argument
ensues why they are bad
if you want to expose corruption within
companies
there are ways you have to go about it
you can shall i say
and the way that they go about it is
primarily through violence
and murder and that does not sit well
yes for the fan watching it votes to see
all the action the violence but when you
look at the morality standard of it
it is wrong they go through this through
all the wrong
channels to try to justify all of the
right
reasons you should not have to kill and
maim
again kidnapping also plays into this
they
kidnapped translucent let's never forget
this and
tortured him on top of all of the other
things so
i feel they're bad
tough break there in uh season one
starting out roxy streier what say you
to counter jay
translucent was peeking on all the women
who were naked in the bathroom
we're not gonna miss him very much
here's why the boys are good
do good people do bad things sometimes
absolutely and mark i would like to
think that you and everybody at home
knows that
i'm a good person you guys are good
people have you ever done something a
little bit wrong
yeah does it mean that you're not a good
person absolutely not you are still good
and so are the boys
they're fighting the bad guys and in
life we've got good and we've got bad
should it be a little more gray than
that
probably but it's really not and these
are the good guys who are taking down
the bad guys
who are drugging babies right like in a
universe where people are drugging
children babies anything else you're
doing
you're probably pretty good if we take
them each individually they've done
such redeeming things like frenchie
who's not able to let the female
die even though it would be so much
better for the rest of the boys
or huey who's constantly learning from
his mistakes and he doesn't let a train
die when he easily could when he's dying
from a heart attack he still makes them
call the police so at the end of the day
in their soul of souls they are driven
by love and does that come out in
revenge sometimes yes but they're still
taking out the bad guys
okay so uh i would agree with roxy at
this point is that even good people do
bad things like when i gave away a
trivia answer
in the pre-show jay 30 seconds to
counter roxy's argument what do you got
for your rebuttal
to say that good people do bad things
we're not gonna play this as
easy as black and white huey is still an
accessory to all of the crimes
particularly murder about translucent
they stuck c4
in the man's rectum that is so many
crimes of wrong
frenchie was also out here doing wrong
billy butcher will you
kill anybody he has to their motives
their ideas may be right but their
motives about it are wrong
think about it they are on the run and
trying not to get
caught in the process because they will
all go to jail
and die you can't just tell if the
police stop them like yo the reason we
killed this superhero
is because the whole corporation is mad
no one's gonna go for that argument
okay roxy uh before i give you 30
seconds reminding all the fans out there
who are commenting
you can vote on who you think had the
better argument click that red button
the heart button if you think jay
is winning this round you think roxy is
that blue thumbs up button is the way to
go and let's see about that counter
roxy 30 seconds these are the spice
girls the spice girls cannot be wrong
listen mothers milk and frenchie both
don't want to come back into butcher's
fold but they
do why do they do it because it's fun
no because they love each other no
because it's the right thing to do and
they both know that in their souls
even though it risks their families and
even though it risks their love lives
they still know this is the right thing
to do because we have to stop the true
evil that's out there and sometimes
in order to stop true evil you have to
get your hands a little dirty doesn't
make you a bad person
okay i'm seeing this go both ways i'm
seeing a lot of thumbs up and a lot of
hearts light up so
the way that we end each round is a
quick 10 second
closing argument jay you're up first
mother's milk left his wife and daughter
to be a part of the boys for what he
believes is a good reason but again is
an accessory to murder kidnapping and so
many other things
if they had about gone about this the
right way and just directly exposed
vaught and soups in the beginning
be no problem rocks it's about the
greater good
not the individual good they're giving
up their
own lives for a higher purpose a higher
power
to fight the bad guys which inherently
makes them
the good guys or should i say good boys
[Laughter]
nice little tag there like i said chat
divided on this one so far danny doherty
says roxy's got this one edward harrell
replies
and says a little wrong if they're a
little wrong i wouldn't want them
very wrong uh joseph burrows thinks that
they're good
and and apparently
i just bought stock and bitcoin so a
little bit everything here
in the chat um as we do get to the votes
and we quickly tally them up once again
for each and every round you think jay
washington won that debate you liked his
rounds better you're gonna vote with
your hearts
i think roxy did a better job you're
gonna vote with the thumbs up
and for this round one the boys good or
bad
roxy streier gets the win and goes up
one-nothing
over jay washington
you're lucky okay you are so lucky for
that are you a ventriloquist what's
happening
yeah i know my soul is somewhere else
right now oh
look at j washington dinner he's really
bitter it doesn't look good on you jay
let's just go to the next question
i've i've i've argued with jay on many a
show and this is one of jay's tactics he
goes to the fake cry ventriloquist act
early
we'll see if it pays off for him roxy
streier
is going to kick off round number two
with this premise
who is the second strongest soups not
homelander
the second strongest roxy stry or one
minute
it's all yours listen homelanders not on
the table because obviously he would be
the strongest so who is the second
strongest
it's the person who's closest to
homelander which is queen maeve
because a she's able to call on him when
she needs
she knows when she needs additional help
and that's really important
she's also as we've seen willing to
severely
injure herself to get ahead like how she
broke every single bone on her arm in
order to save a bunch of people
now has she been hardened over time yes
absolutely
but that's actually made her even
stronger because now she has the ability
to compartmentalize like she couldn't
before we've also seen her use her sex
appeal to get what she wants
she's able to convince homelander of
things when nobody
else is and when you talk about strength
we're not just talking about physical
strength we're talking about ability to
get the job done
so she's able to save starlight's life
because she looks at homelander and says
i've got this nobody else would be able
to do this
on top of that she's obviously
bulletproof she's got incredible super
strength
she's unbelievable in hand-to-hand
combat and
she cannot fly this is true but anytime
she needs a flight
trust me there's mad men out there
including homelander himself
who wouldn't mind giving her a little
bit of a ride
again pun intended it's a good argument
because yeah
it's nice to be in the gym and it's nice
to have emotional strength but the
bulletproof thing
really steals the deal so jay washington
what is your answer second
strongest character if it's not homeland
it would always be perceived that the
second strongest will be put
right next to the first strong the
overall strongest but the person in
which we don't
see fully but we've seen glimpses of are
that of black noir
black noir who we see silent but deadly
speaks volumes no matter what i could go
to his comic book lore
but that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about a dude when he has
his fight with the woman
we see how deadly he is as a ninja his
martial arts skills
his quickness his stealthness his
devotion to the seven no matter what
throughout everything else with queen
maeve we see her fall back
he is devoted to the seven despite
anything else his strength
lies in his convictions and belief for
him to be as stoic as he
is and also has had some of the best
funny moments he goes to play a piano
and says nothing and the guy playing the
piano realizes
i just need to move the black noir keeps
knives and daggers to throw at a
moment's notice on various parts of his
body
he is bulletproof he is just as strong
he
is just as quick as any other ones he
don't need sex appeal he at all black
that's just sexy by his damn self
yeah that's uh uh not as surprising as a
comedian who's had multiple tv
appearances you pick black mart not only
because of the ability but also
the comedic moments are pretty sweet too
roxy you're back up with a 30 second
rebuttal
are we stronger as one or are we
stronger individually
because black noir is a one-man band
he does not help get help from anybody
he does not ask for help he doesn't even
speak
yes he is devoted to the seven so you're
just gonna assume that that makes him
strong
i think we have pretty much proved that
they're the
bad guys here so usually good triumphs
over evil
yeah he's bulletproof yet he doesn't
have any emotions but that doesn't
actually give you
strength he's not able to reach inside
himself and fight for the greater good
because it's not inside him he's just
kind of a robot who just does what he's
told and keeps his head down and does
the job
all right this is really becoming maybe
a good versus evil or
inner strength versus outer strength so
jay if you're watching broken j
no i was just wondering how long you
were gonna go okay
it's all yours now jay you need strength
when you're part of the team
he doesn't need anybody that backs him
up homelander needs
nobody queen maeve needs the team she
needs
homelander black noir strength is shown
by his
own prowess we're asking the question
who is the second strongest suit
the lack of emotion and the lack to not
the ability to not have to connect
makes him just as strong because why
emotions can bring you
down the motions have sometimes set
queen maeve back
emotions will not set black noir back
i'm loving what this chat is bringing to
the table too john lee says not sure but
the visuals clicking
uh matling says you barely get to see
black noir in action so he would have
chosen starlight
and garth hartness mcmurray simplifies
it for us
roxy picks their wonder woman jay picks
their batman he thinks
roxy has this one so for now we're going
to do a 10-second
closing argument but i am going to let
you all for the remainder of the rounds
no more closing argument it's just going
to be that minute in that 30 seconds so
this
time you get your 10-second closer roxy
you're up first
here's the thing she's able to get other
people to do things because she uses
empathy
he is unable to do that and also you're
right we can't pull from the comic books
we haven't seen it on the tv show we
don't know what black noir is capable of
yet because we've barely seen it and
little comedic relief
that's it if we made it as strong as you
say she isn't
able to use empathy to get people to do
what she wanted to do she would have
stopped homelander
and had him actually land that plane
instead of letting 200 some people die
man this is where it got heated if you
thought the first round was good that
was just the warm up to what we just
witnessed a lot of thumbs a lot of
hearts racing up the charts here
and it does appear that mr j washington
has tied it with his heart
it is one two one here again you're
clicking with your hearts to vote for
jay you're clicking with your thumbs
to vote for roxy's finest
i don't know whether it's against me or
maeve but one of us
one of us you know i do recall uh
there was a great game between the
patriots and the bears tom brady's first
season when he did lead them to that
first super bowl and that one came down
to the wire
we could have a repeat of that right now
with jay washington stepping up to go
first in round three and jay
this is a category that is right up your
alley because the question is simple
best wtf moments
what do you got there are a myriad
amount of wtf moments
within this entire series first season i
mentioned one with translucent having a
piece of c4 stuck up his rectum
there are so many others we can go to
what i brought up in just the
previous round the plane crash but the
most
wtf moment is pop claw
crushing the head of her landlord while
she is riding his
face i am going to say this and be
straightforward
that is something a man has happened and
he is enjoying it in the moment
a woman is there for pleasure but she is
spazzing out on compound v
and whatever else and her thighs get way
too tight
and she squeezing that man head open
like a cassava mellow and all his stuff
and all he wanted was the rent he didn't
want nothing else she put that on that
man
and broke his head open and it made a
lot of dudes feel nervous after that for
a while
it uh it did remind me of that scene
from goldeneye a little bit with fancy
chances you go back watch smoothie you
know which one i'm talking about
roxy minute is on the clock for you
honestly i think he died the most happy
death that any man has ever
died didn't know him don't know her that
well couldn't care
less that he is gone or that she killed
him with her punan
here's the truth you just used this in
order to win your last argument and now
i'm gonna throw it in your face because
the biggest wtf moment absolutely is the
plane crash in episode four
this is something that changed the
stakes of this entire show
we had already seen that homelander was
bad but we did not know to what level
and we didn't know where queen maeve
stood
and now we knew he was up there he could
have saved
some people maybe not everyone but
definitely some people
and that lazy ass of his was like wait
you want me to go down
and then back up and get more people and
bring them down
absolutely not and when she tries to
save a child's life
he says no they will tell they'll tell
what happened
this is the moment we know this is not a
regular show this
is next level messed up and it really
introduced us to who homelander is
at his core it did not have to happen
and it blew
everyone's mind it took over twitter and
my world for the time
we have a lot of comments uh supporting
the dolphin we have a lot of comments
supporting the b
plane obviously and uh garth chimes in
thank you garth uh is garth says this is
family friendly so what does wtf stand
for way too fun
sure sure that's what we'll go with
we'll say
is it family friendly when you die by
vagina
i mean right can i start my 30 seconds
rebuttal
thank you okay the plane crash was a wtf
moment because we saw everything but we
had inklings
and we knew kind of started dropping
dimes as to what homelander was
who he was as a prick for lack of better
words but to watch pop claw
who just broke and everybody had to
watch it on camera
as she rode dude's face and he was in
the moment like
and then it just exploded you know what
i'm saying that is not the way you want
to go there are things you plan on after
that nobody is going to say
if i die i want to die on my face no
just like the color purple she died on
top of me
nobody wanted that uh
once again you're voting with your
hearts for jay you're voting with your
thumbs up for
roxy roxy before i give you 30 seconds
jay can you do that impression one more
time
which one the noise you
made of dude nobody was
what was that his life he gets five
additional seconds for an impression i
should get that too
i will give roxy 35 seconds and
occasionally even i good guy mark
ellis have to abuse my hosting abilities
roxy 35 seconds
is all yours jay i literally feel like
you picked the biggest hell yeah moment
in the entire show
yeah like that was hell yeah i could
watch that on repeat that's my type of
porn baby
this is a incredible moment in which
it's a guy that dies that i do not know
and i do not care about in a tv show if
it's gonna be a wtf moment
you have to lose one of the main
characters you have to lose somebody
that your heart and soul is attached to
i don't care about this landlord i do
not care that you're gone and honestly i
barely cared about popcorn
like at all so we're talking about
falling in love with people
on an airplane little children children
are dying
what the actual f is happening here how
can these things be compared
a whole bunch of hundreds of people
dying versus one person dying by vagina
that's okay
take it so i imagine uh john evans is
referring to that death
when uh simply comments thoughts and
prayers anthony alicia chimes in but the
dolphin
though and danny doherty says
that danny was rooting for roxy but at
least according to danny in this round
jay takes that point jelani jones with a
great
point that's how i want to die though
and we have confirmation of roxy's dark
side
thanks to matt link and so seeing a lot
of
hearts and a lot of thumbs up but we're
tallying up the final votes and it does
appear i don't know what she was able to
do with that last five seconds jay but
i think that's what won her the point
roxy streier
wins round three and gets back on top by
a point
we fell in love with the people on the
plane we didn't even know those people
was a kid
she was a little girl she was a little
child jay
i mean we really wanted to go to the
real wtf moment
it's old girl fingering the deep's gills
that's the real deal that was messed up
too
she was like in his side and then he was
like stop stop
maybe you should have picked that one i
should have never
as a professional broadcaster have i
been happier to hear the word gills
thank you we move on to round number
four
where roxy could win or jay could tie it
up and force
sudden death overtime we're about to
find out because roxy you are kicking
this round off
with your minute on the clock and the
topic the
best character pretty straightforward
but there's going to be a lot of debate
in the chat so
light it up for us roxy without a doubt
the best character on the show is
starlight
and i think that people don't want to
give her that credit because it's the
easy pick but sometimes in life the easy
pick is the right pick
she's the best person on the show she is
our moral compass
she's still finding her power so she's
interesting to watch it's not boring or
bland yes she has a lot of religious
beliefs but she's struggling with those
as well and we're making discoveries
alongside her
she stands up for what is right she's
got a great love interest on the show
with huey
we love watching their relationship she
isn't annoying or judgy like a lot of
preachy
uh religious characters on shows or fish
out of water on shows characters can be
she's just really good not to mention
she's absolutely beautiful
with the costume situation she's always
on the right side of everything
but she's still got a little edge to her
because at the end of the day
she doesn't stick with her team she's
kind of that crossover player and we
don't know what she's going to do so a
lot of the show's mystery
also comes from her she is the leading
factor in why this show is fun to watch
and she's also a really cool character
in general
all right pretty strong opening argument
there for starlight jay washington now
you have a minute to tell us
why your best character is the best
when you look at the boys and the
characters they want you to focus on
it's billy butcher huey and starlight
those are the easiest choices which
seems why you picked one
but the best character in itself is the
character with depth and a lot of
a lot of layers mother's milk liz alonso
brings you a character
who has stepped away from this world
entirely
he didn't want to be in it anymore but
billy butcher pulls him back in and even
though he's pulled back in
he is still trying to maintain his level
of sanity and humanity
the best part i think it's episode three
when he's on the phone with his wife and
he's like oh baby i forgot to marinate
the tilapia
don't trip him and go pick up some
tenderloins some portobello mushrooms
and that pinot you like
he's still trying to be a family man
because that's all he
wants to be and we see that we also see
he tries to have a calm demeanor
throughout the entire show
but people keep pushing him over the
edge and when you push him
over the edge he gets that level of
violence that even butcher sometimes is
shocked about
all right that's mother's milk and uh a
lot of people having a side debate is
the
homelander being the worst character the
best character so
while that rage is on friendly reminder
you're voting with your hearts the red
button for jay you're voting with your
thumbs up the blue button for roxy
this could be the last round of binge
battle today so roxy
you got 30 seconds to try to get the win
if mother's milk is not on the show
the show is still literally exactly the
same like he does not bring that much to
the show
he's such a side character and he's fine
i have no
issue with mother's milk but i'm not in
love with him i don't wait for him to
come on the screen
when he's there i'm like you're nice to
look at uh he
honestly does not add that much value
and he might in season two but season
one he doesn't
starlight has great morals and by the
way team in the chat
i'm for the fact that she's incredibly
religious and she brings that to the
show we
need that element of her on the show
because we need somebody who's connected
to what is right
and what is wrong and that's what that
stands for here and we especially on a
show with the boys where we're arguing
morality
she is our morality not
you're mother's milk him you say
morality and you're talking about a man
who has to choose between his friends
and his family
his she leaves her family to starlight
leaves her family to join the seven
because she's happy to do it even though
it's what her mother wants
but mother's milk is reluctant the
entire time laz alonso is the heart
behind everything huey's the cute little
guy because we start out with his story
but you have mother's milk who keeps
everything grounded keeps the boys more
focused than even billy butcher can
so many likes so many hearts and so many
different
codes of silver is one thing that struck
me about the boys season one one of the
reasons why i enjoy the show so much is
just
everybody has their own weird moral
compass where if you look at it in the
landscape of the greater good
none of them are on par with just doing
justice
serving the community with no underlying
emotional attachments to themselves or
to something else
that may portray them as selfish or less
than holy and that's the beauty of it is
that this is probably how
superheroes would act in real life and
when we look at all the hearts
and we tabulate all of the thumbs up we
take roxy starlight
versus jay washington's mother's milk
jay fighting valiantly to force a
tiebreaker
unfortunately it is roxy streier
taking down jay washington jay i'm sorry
roxy you did it
in regulation three rounds to one over
jay washington congratulations roxy
streier
celebrates i am celebrating with my arms
i've never done this before look at this
dance what's happening she can't help it
jay you defeated defeated look i don't i
don't
win with um grace nobody said i did
when you win as much as the boston teams
do you make it a little spoiled jay
you fought valiantly you went down
swinging
what do you have to say for yourself i
didn't in my heart believe that the boys
are bad
i had to argue that with the people and
i gave it my all
like i'm a lawyer in a tv show okay like
a matthew mcconaughey at a
and y'all turned on me we both made
compromises jay we both compromised our
dignity
you didn't have to compromise as much
okay you didn't have to change as much
oh here's this but congratulations you
win
oh this is this is so funny we have so
many people this homelander debate is
still going on brian knight says
negative points for roxy and jay because
they didn't pick
homeland or sorry i don't make the rules
um
danny doherty says he loves all three of
us which i think is a nice sentiment
and one of my favorite comments is from
jaron evans who says
where's molly to guest judge molly the
wonder dog the beagle boston terry that
is still asleep
in the other room so molly is not waking
up yet despite
the fact that her dad is talking in his
dad hosting voice so
she's taking a nap but roxy streier is
on cloud night we'll put jay on the
cloud seven or eight he had a great
showing today so
i want to reward both of my competitors
with their streaming picks to give to
all of our fans out there who've been
awesome across all platforms
well into the thousands of people
watching us over the
youtube for rotten tomatoes for fandango
movie clips and then here joining us on
facebook as well
so jay as the runner-up you get first
shot
at your streaming recommendation what do
you want all the fans out there to check
out
uh for me i think in the midst of all
the craziness and madness that it is in
this world we need to have something of
a little bit of heart and just take us
back to a level innocence
thundercats both the original season
from 1985 and the 2011 season are
available on
stream and i highly recommend you do it
you can go binge out on it and don't
have to worry about the world around you
i i agree with some folks in the chat
here when they're
they're referencing jay and there's a
crocodile that was found that was like
25 feet long
and has eaten like 30 people and his
name is gustav and i still don't think
gustav has wept as many crocodile tears
as jay washington is that fair to say
jay
i don't i don't wanna dignify that
okay you know what i know where you live
i'm going to come give you a hug right
now
a social distant hug i'm going to wear
my mask roxy where can everybody find
your streaming pick what do you got for
him
working moms i think you're going to
like that one mark because it's a
katherine reitman show who
i think is a a friend of yours but she
made this incredible show that is on
netflix now it came from that canadian
station that gave us
uh shit's creek as well and this show is
phenomenal i'd never heard of it all of
a sudden i'm scrolling through netflix
there's four seasons of it and i was
like what is working moms
this show is raunchy it is weird it's
funny to the point that you are
crying laughing but going like this at
the same time because you can't even
watch the screen it's so uncomfortable
uh it's got a bunch of badass women in
it and
i i can't believe the show isn't bigger
i think it's gonna do a shit's creek
thing where it kind of
builds as now it's available on netflix
so can't recommend this show
enough especially during a time where we
all need to laugh this is the show
i would agree with that and both y'all
streaming picks i appreciate because
they are
a nice distraction sometimes we need our
art to comment on what's going on and
sometimes we just want to get out of our
own head and out of the news for a
little bit so
you got thundercats got working moms
katherine reitman is a longtime friend
of mine and she is doing an incredible
job
on that program as did both competitors
here today before we plug everything
that they have going on in the latest
places you can catch i'm going to remind
you all
that binge battle is brought to you by
rotten tomatoes and we want you to check
out
binge central that's at
rottentomatoes.com just click that for
all the latest streaming info
you get updates you get news you have a
bunch of cool lists that the staff has
worked tirelessly to compile
all the everything from the best hundred
action movies currently streaming to
the 10 best tv shows of days gone by
that you missed
and you can catch right now so go check
out binge central that
hub for everything streaming right now
jay washington i know you always have a
thousand things going on where can all
the kids find you what do you want to
give a shout out to right now
uh i just want to give a shout out to
rotten tomatoes to you mark and to you
roxy you guys are great friends of mine
and i always love doing this with you
all cause that's what makes it better
like if i lost to somebody i wasn't
really cool with i'd be
so badly but it's like okay me and roxy
will laugh about it later but anyway you
can find me twitter and instagram at mr
j washington
m-r-j-a-y you should know how to spell
washington please do
uh the mad titan podcast i'll get you
caught up on all the things happened in
the marvel and dc
live-action cinematic universes it is
barbershop talk but nerd so come on in
that convo
and blurts in the hood every tuesday
live
myself and my co-host winston a marshall
2 p.m pacific
5 pm on the east coast on our youtube
channel youtube.com
slash blurs in the hood that's b l e r d
s the letter
n t h e h o d and we're possibly adding
the second show in the week
that's right i uh i i think that we can
put to rest the debate
from winston and jay who's pippin who's
jordan it's just two michael jordans on
that show two of my great friends and
if you've never seen jay do stand up
dude as an absolute monster on stage i
hope to get back up there live with you
soon my man
a lot of people are afraid to try stand
up one of them may not be roxy star with
her new show the whirl girls where
they're trying different things
during the pandemic planning things
after this is over so roxy
what's the latest experiment from you
stephen dorina on
the world girls oh i'm still afraid of
stand up mark i'm so afraid
uh we are giving bottle rockets a whirl
that episode is dropping soon we're
world girl wednesdays every single
wednesday and
it was a disaster i can't i can't
express enough
how much we are not scientists uh so
definitely check that out
and then yeah i'm everywhere at roxy
stream shout out to alex and ed and
everybody from rotten tomatoes team
really appreciate you guys having us
mark you as well
you're amazing and jay um i know i
didn't lose in grace but if i'm gonna
beat anybody
uh you're such a worthy com opponent
that i'm glad that it was you
thank you so much i appreciate hearing
those words and alex and ed you all are
amazing too
all our entire tech team is the best and
when whenever roxy's describing bottle
rockets and it went horribly wrong
i'm glad she shows us that she still has
10 digits to brag about so
i didn't show you my talent you can
check out live at the roxy daily on
youtube what jay said check out boards
in the hood follow them on all the
social media stuff and as for me
live at the viper room virtually from
wherever you are your living room your
car your bathroom
come watch and hang out tickets are as
low as 12 mark ellislive.net
the last shout out of the day is me
echoing roxy and j
sentiment when i say everybody behind
the scenes here at rotten tomatoes
one of the hardest working best tech
crews in the entire industry
helping us engineer this baby across
multiple platforms
so for everyone behind the scenes and in
front of the camera
i am mark ellis thanking fandango rotten
tomatoes movie clips and everyone else
and especially
all you fans for chiming in for voting
and making binge battle the success it
is we'll be back with a new episode soon
in the meantime
have a great day
you